into the soft light of this Florida Don
emerges friendship 7 making its debut to
the day of its destiny
the mercury Atlas stands long waiting to
depart this earth a quarter of a million
pounds of rocket with thrust equal to
three and a half million horsepower all
two hurdle 168 pound astronaut into
space
astronaut John Glenn of New Concord Ohio
lieutenant colonel United States Marine
Corps married father of two teenage
children Glenn has been a pilot over
half of his 40 years has flown in two
wars and as a veteran test pilot who
five years earlier established a
transcontinental flight record as the
first man to average supersonic speeds
across America he volunteered for space
flight is one of seven astronauts
selected for Project Mercury the man and
space program directed by the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration
never in all of history have so many
people shared an adventure of such
magnitude the time nears and soon this
earth path indicator in the capsule will
begin showing John Glenn his changing
positions above the world ladies check
pressurization locks taking now a
blinking high-level light you are gold
order systems girl range operations
castle go all pre start power lights are
correct the ready light is on he checked
with the umbilical I'll evacuate portree
umbilical clear mercury is no it lights
on all recorders to fast D minus 18
seconds and counting engine start
hey the we will see Ricky from oh good
lord ride all the ways you've got speed
John Glenn ten nine eight seven
[Applause]
[Music]
your backup clock is started one oxygen
78
[Music]
[Applause]
seventy seconds leaving a nice paper
trail now looks real fine tape is going
I am go dancer is in good shape all
systems are go Seco sustainer engine
cutoff the moment when the final Atlas
engine will shut down when friendship
seven should separate from the booster
rocket and begin orbital flight go
classic rates fired okay
Rogers zero-g and I feel fine capsule is
turning around oh that view is
tremendous
[Music]
to John Glenn now belongs an awesome
panorama the world curving beneath him
just as it was filmed from an earlier
mercury capsule you have a go at least
seven orbits understand for at least
seven orbits clear back up big crowd
water way back across toward the Cape
beautiful sight
[Music]
you